bien lire et à
bien sûr
au retour nous ollier pour
habitant un petit temps qui lui permet
de remporter l'étape cesbron et du même
coup la coupe qui la crise est prévue
14h45 pour alain gautier le dit m à 22
ans la première partie complète
c'est surtout inattendue en fait parce
que dans cette course ya quand même
beaucoup de très très bons coureurs qui
sont à venir du très bon matériel et est
en fait qu est qu'ils sont venus pour
gagner laurent bourgnon ademi toute sa
fortune dans son bateau coque anciennes
et voile bien usé son spi et son génois
lui avait même été prêté par ses
adversaires
peut-être que quelque part ça ça ça
motive parce qu'on a tous mis je suis
jusqu'au bout jusqu'au dernier centime
pour pour réussir et donc donc on n'a
pas envie de perdre son temps sur l'eau
et on se bat à fond pour faire la
meilleure place le grand perdant c'est
lui alain gautier encalminé à quelques
milles de l'arrivée il est resté deux
heures sans bouger trois étals gagner
pour rien son avance a fondu entre
kinsale et quiberon il termine second
prévenu devenu laurent bourgnon
vainqueur sans se mêler au combat